Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas we
have now learned has been for years
claiming income from a company that did
not actually exist when he said he
earned income from that company now is
this simply a paperwork mistake or an
innocent mix-up or is it the latest in
multiple new chapters of the questions
surrounding Clarence Thomas we are going
to discuss all of it now you may be
saying David I just heard something
about Clarence Thomas a week and a half
ago before you left you told us about
Clarence Thomas's Financial relationship
with a billionaire vacations Yachts all
sorts of different things and yes that
is indeed true but there are now
multiple new allegations against
Clarence Thomas so let's jump into the
first one this is from a Washington Post
investigation which says Clarence Thomas
has for years claimed income from a
defunct real estate firm
the misstatements which began when a
family business transferred its Holdings
to another company are part of a pattern
that has raised questions about how the
Supreme Court Justice views his
obligation to accurately report details
about his finances to the public the
details are actually relatively
straightforward here over the last two
decades Clarence Thomas has reported on
financial disclosure forms that his
family was receiving rental income to
the tune of hundreds of thousands of
dollars from a company called ginger
limited partnership that company which
is a Nebraska Real Estate firm launched
in the 1980s has not existed since 2006
okay that's 17 years that this company
has not existed that company was shut
down and a separate firm was created the
similarly named firm assumed control of
the shuttered company but Clarence
Thomas keeps reporting that he's making
between fifty and a hundred thousand
dollars a year from that company there
is no mention of the actual company that
exists Ginger Holdings LLC now could
this just be an innocent paperwork error
well the article addresses that it says
the previously unreported misstatement
might be dismissed as a paperwork error
but it is among a series of errors and
omissions that Thomas has made on these
forms over the last many decades and if
you take them all together there are a
number of red flags here now this is not
the only
new controversy involving Clarence
Thomas the Grio reports Thomas sold real
estate to a donor and didn't report that
he did that this is this is yet another
one of these oh it's a mistake which
just by coincidence makes it seem as
though Thomas has has fewer Financial
entanglements with donors and influence
Peddlers the Grio reports the 2014 real
estate deal
shines a new light on Thomas's
decades-old relationship with Harlan
Crowe that is the real estate magnate
and financier for conservative claw
causes who I told you about a week and a
half ago and indeed Harlan Crowe bought
properties three properties belonging to
Clarence Thomas and his family in a
transaction worth more than a hundred
thousand dollars that Thomas did not
ever report so listen Clarence Thomas
should resign the totality of the
financial picture here is an absolute
nightmare over the weekend I read about
something called The Abe Fortis
president Fortis is spelled
f-o-r-t-a-s Abe Fortis was a Supreme
Court Justice appointed by LBJ in 1965.
he was nominated by LBJ to Chief Justice
in 68 but that nomination was eventually
withdrawn because of controversy related
to his financial dealings and the Fortis
president precedent refers to this kind
of tradition that has emerged since his
nomination was withdrawn which suggests
Supreme Court nominees who have been the
subject of significant controversy or
opposition during their confirmation
process may not be successful in their
bid for appointment to the court so in
other words the idea is if a supreme
court nominee becomes too controversial
they
um ultimately are not going to succeed
and it's been cited a whole bunch of
different times it came up with Brett
Kavanaugh we know Brett Kavanaugh
ultimately did become Supreme Court
Justice Etc and the idea here is it's
time to go it's time to get out now
whether this actually is going to come
to force when it comes to Clarence
Thomas
is is unclear but the argument that's
being made is this all actually goes
back to Clarence Thomas's start on the
court it goes back to those hearings
where Clarence Thomas was accused of
sexual harassment
and we should have known at the time
that he was unfit to serve on the court
that in a way telegraphed or predicted
what ultimately is coming to pass with
Clarence Thomas which is a sort of
20-year record of endless forms of
financial impropriety questions which
ultimately are going to force him off
the court now do I believe Clarence
Thomas is actually going to be forced
off of the court I really don't
I really don't and one of the things
that we have seen is that while on paper
there are all sorts of different rules
and conventions and stipulations and
laws
when they are actually challenged just
because a check or balance is there
in writing does not mean it will
actually be enforced we've seen so many
Hatch Act violations during the Trump
Administration kellyanne Conway and
others it all went nowhere we've seen
all sorts of violations of the way
presidents are supposed to comport
themselves during the Trump
Administration and at least for the most
part there have been no consequences so
do I believe that Thomas should resign
of course
do I believe that Clarence Thomas has
violated those judicial canons which say
that judges and justices should avoid
not only actual impropriety but even the
appearance of impropriety of course
that's been violated by Clarence Thomas
but do I believe he will actually be
held accountable for it I don't if you
do
I want to hear from you because if
anything we've learned over the last six
years that unless we really have a
system not only willing to have checks
and balances but to actually enforce
them and hold people accountable for
them nothing happens and that's been the
greatest lesson of the last six years
for me
Republicans are now staging ridiculous
hearings in New York City on violent
crime these are Republicans from the
House of Representatives anybody say
David wait a second House of
Representatives Washington D.C federal
government why are they holding these
hearings in New York City the reason
they are doing it
is because they are trying to run
interference for Donald Trump's
indictment and arrest by attacking Alvin
Bragg with the idea why is Bragg going
after Trump when Bragg has violence in
New York City to deal with now of course
you and I probably see that and say wait
a second prosecutors can do multiple
things at once one of the problems we
have in the United States which I've
pointed out is that there is too much
focus on Street crime rather than
corporate financial and white-collar
crime that doesn't mean we ignore
violent crime it means that we have a
system that at its systemic structural
level
focuses on one type of crime and not the
other and that leads to a
disproportionate focus on wealthy people
I'm sorry not unwealthy people but
rather on poor people we've talked about
this before low effort low hanging fruit
policing for example makes it much
easier to just go to a poor neighborhood
and you know harass people stop and
frisk Etc and not actually partake in
the other types of investigative work
that we should be seeing so Alvin Bragg
is doing nothing wrong but Republicans
want to make the case there's violence
in New York and Alvin Bragg is indicting
Trump for nonsense the other element to
this is that we have a red State murder
problem and a red City violent crime
problem but Republicans don't want you
to know that they want you to believe oh
it's liberal cities that are dangerous
and that's it so let's take this from
the top NBC news reports Trump allies
take fight to Bragg's backyard with
hearing on New York City crime the
Manhattan district attorney Prosecuting
Donald Trump highlights new police data
that shows murders and under other
violent crimes have actually fallen in
the borough since last year there's a
picture on the screen of Republican
Congressman Jim Jordan
uh because he is leading this uh these
series of hearings as absurd as they are
the argument that Republicans want to
make is Democrats are weak on crime as
it is uh blue cities have a crime
problem and Alvin Bragg epitomizes this
problem by going after Trump rather than
going after the violent crime well Eric
Adams the mayor of New York City was on
MSNBC this morning and he accurately and
rightly pointed out that not only is
this a political stunt but there is
actually a bigger problem with violent
crime in many republican cities here's
Eric Adams why let's bring in the mayor
of New York City Eric Adams by the way
what do you think of this field Hearing
in your city about crime I think is the
highest level of hypocrisy
we know that cities all across America
are dealing with the issues around
Public Safety particularly the criminal
justice system and right in the largest
city in Ohio I was reported today in one
of the tabloids of the murders of over
50 percent in the first quarter and so
while crime is going down homicides are
going down here Shooters are going down
here some of the major uh crimes you're
trending in the right direction our
subway system crime is going down so I
think coming here and highlighting uh
D.A Bragg it's just really a political
stunt now is Eric Adams correct yes he
is it is true that in New York City in
2022 there was a violent crime rate a
homicide rate of 5.2 per hundred
thousand people whereas in Columbus Ohio
there was a homicide rate of 15.4 per
100 000 people the homicide rate in 2022
was nearly three times higher in Ohio
than it was in New York City we've
talked about both violent and property
crime rates being higher in Oklahoma
City a red City in a red State then in
New York City and New York State and
then there is also something as I
mentioned earlier called the Red State
murder problem in 2020
per capita murder rates were 40 percent
higher in States Trump won than in
States Biden won 40 percent higher if
you look at 2020 at the 10 states with
the highest murder rates eight of them
voted for the Presidential nominee from
the Republican party in every election
this Century so far now I don't want to
do the thing that the right does on so
many different issues whether it's gas
prices or debt and deficit and whatever
and pretend that the entire Crime Story
is just a matter of when Republicans are
in charge it's more dangerous because
that's actually not so clearly the case
and what I mean by that is crime is
multi-dimensional and very complicated
crime can be influenced by many
different factors it often also
fluctuates from year to year when you
look at crime you have to look at
poverty
inequality which we know as a big impact
on crime education levels per capita
income the relationship between
political affiliation and crime rates is
one Element and it's not straightforward
but the reason I bring all of this up to
you is that the right-wing Narrative of
dangerous Democratic cities or states or
whatever it's absolutely and completely
bogus now I do want to give you one
other
uh I don't even know what this is I I
want to advise you of one other way in
which this conversation is often
mishandled by many there's a game that
can be played which is you can say oh
you know what red states are far more
dangerous on average than blue States oh
okay
so then Republicans will come in and say
no no no no no but the problem is even
within the red States most of the
violence is in the blue cities but then
you can come back and say well hold on a
second
just the fact that the violence is in
the cities doesn't really mean it's
because of Democrats because much of
this policy is set at the state level
and the state legislature and the state
senate are Republican and then you can
go back and say well but within the
cities the crime is mostly within the
districts that are from democratic City
councilors okay I think you get the
point that this can be sliced and diced
a whole bunch of different ways so my
message here isn't to say it is because
of Republicans necessarily in every case
that violent crime and homicide and all
these things are higher the point is the
right wing story about crime in Democrat
cities so-called is completely and
totally wrong but what this is all about
is interference running interference for
Trump and his indictment when Trump was
arrested and indicted a week and a half
ago the strategy was very clear what can
Republicans in the house do to help
Donald Trump and one of the things Jim
Jordan has chosen to do is to have these
absurd hearings in New York City rather
than in Washington DC where they should
be in order to try to distract I don't
think it'll work we'll be watching them
closely and we'll have clips for you
later this week
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
the David pakman show is Independent
Media we do depend on your support to do
what we do and the best and most direct
way to support our work is simply to get
a membership at joinpakman.com we do an
extra show every day for our members
today I've got actually a I I think much
of today's bonus show will be some
stories from my trip and it was quite a
trip including a an interesting
confrontation with a customs officer
which I think will titillate many uh all
of that and more on the bonus show but
you can sign up at joinpakman.com and
you can use the coupon code indite if
you would like indict actually and
indicted both work uh joinpakman.com as
if you didn't already suspect that Nikki
Haley's 2024 Republican presidential
campaign was off to a bad start we've
learned that she has been dramatically
overstating the amount of money she has
raised and the campaign looks to be I
don't want to say dead on a ride but
very very close so the Washington Post
reporting Nikki Haley's campaign vastly
overstating her fundraising listen to
this instead of the 11 million dollars
touted by her campaign
Haley brought in about 8.3 million not
all of which can even be used for the
presidential campaign they had been
talking about 11 million in six weeks
but now that the filings have been made
with the FEC that was an over
exaggeration the campaign appears to
have double counted money it moved among
various committings committees the
filings covering the first three months
of the year show that three committees
affiliated with Haley collectively
brought in 8.3 million
um
Haley's joint fundraising committee
raised about 4.4 million the campaign
committee's Hall of 5.1 million included
1.8 million from that other committee so
a bunch of that money was double counted
and this is all being considered highly
unusual the Trump campaign Saturday said
they brought in about 14 and a half
million and then another 4.3 million
into the leadership pack and on and on
and on now the funniest part of this is
not all of that 8.3 million can actually
be used for the campaign
because the leadership pack is
um typically only to boost allies or to
promote a message not directly to
finance her own campaign so listen this
is pretty bad this is pretty bad and
there's two ways to interpret this one
way to interpret it is the fact that
Nikki even raised eight even though she
can only use a fraction of it that's
already amazing for a candidate who
isn't doing that well in the polls the
Counterpoint would be this is probably
the most attention she will ever get
this was the big moment and she still
wasn't able to raise that much money and
it didn't do anything for her in the
polling and indeed the polling doesn't
look very good uh her best poll right
now is a particular Iowa poll which
which has her in third place at 14
behind Trump and a guy who's not even
running yet Rhonda Santos that's her
best showing most polling has Nikki
Haley at two three or four percent for
example in the Kentucky primary she's at
four percent in the Georgia primary she
is at four percent so a couple different
thoughts here one I don't think we had
to wait for these numbers from both
polling and fundraising
to be able to say this campaign's
probably not going anywhere at the same
time there's the perspective that the
campaign doesn't really need to go
anywhere in the sense that
Nikki Haley I mean listen you know
people have asked me before when someone
like Nikki Haley announces given what
the polling is does Nikki Haley actually
think she can win I don't know the
answer I've never actually asked these
candidates do you don't really think you
can win do you
um I'm sure she wouldn't admit it if she
didn't think she could win but there's a
particularly unique situation in this in
this 2024 Republican primary which is
Nikki Haley could be running as an
audition for VP that's something that's
been discussed and that I think should
be considered and not ruled out sure she
might be running for VP Trump certainly
seems to think that she is and also
there is the usefulness of more
candidates to Trump because when you
look at 2024 polling one of the things
that you'll notice is in head-to-head
matchups between Trump and DeSantis
DeSantis does better not better than
Trump he's still mostly losing to Trump
but he does better than when you have
Trump DeSantis Haley Pence Tim Scott
Vivek ramaswami and whoever else the
more candidates you have
um the better it actually is for Trump
so there's also the speculation or the
idea that Trump liked the idea of Nikki
Haley running because it actually helps
him needless to say this is a campaign
that as a presidential campaign was
doomed from day one as a vice
presidential audition remains to be seen
uh and we will indeed see that now
someone who's fundraising has been
supercharged over the last couple of
weeks is Donald Trump Donald Trump's
campaign grifting I'm sorry sorry
fundraising has really been supercharged
by his arrest although I don't think
that tells us anything about what this
does for him in a potential general
election match-up and my opinion is that
the arrest is very bad for Trump
Politico is reporting indictment turbo
charges Trump's fundraising the former
president's two political entities
brought in 18 0.8 million during the
first quarter of this year now of course
that predates the arrest but the article
reads Trump raised the combined 18.8
million in the first quarter
but the campaign says and again remember
until they make the FEC filing the fact
that they say they've raised this much
money is it has not been proven but
let's give them the benefit of the doubt
even though they lie all the time and
say we believe them they say that they
were able to raise
15.4 million dollars in just two weeks
after charges were filed against Trump
which is a suggestion that Trump is
growing as fundraising base and it says
nearly a quarter of those who
contributed to Trump during that
two-week period after the arrest had
never given to Trump before
I remain convinced
that the arrest is good for Trump in the
primary and not good for Trump in the
general election I believe and it seems
clear from the data from the claims
we'll get the data at the end of the
quarter but it seems clear that when you
see wow accelerated fundraising for
Trump after the arrest and also a
quarter of the donors never donated to
Trump before it certainly is feasible to
believe from that
that there are existing Republicans and
likely
Trump supporters who just never donated
before maybe because they couldn't
afford to maybe because they can't
really afford to now and still shouldn't
be no donating to Trump who after all is
a billionaire why does Trump need to
fundraise if he's a billionaire and the
whole thing was I don't need anybody's
money I can finance my own campaign okay
put that aside
I don't doubt that the counter narrative
and the propaganda that Trump and others
are spreading about the arrest is
helping Trump raise money from Maga
types and I don't doubt that this may
even help Trump's polling which we will
be looking at on tomorrow's program in
the primary but as far as the general
election goes if Trump is indeed the
nominee I don't think this gets him a
single additional vote I don't see any
way that it does the folks who are
actually connected to reality and look
at things in a sane and sober way are
overwhelmingly going to see Trump as a
chaotic and beleaguered candidate
because of the arrest so I'm with many
on the right who have been saying this
seals Trump's primary Victory I don't
disagree that that's an accurate
interpretation of what is going on
I don't think this is good for Trump in
the general and of course I'm making a
prediction and we will have to wait and
see
the Trump versus DeSantis elements of
the primary are getting ugly even though
Ron DeSantis still hasn't even announced
that he is running a pro-desantis pack
has released an ad which ran for the
first time on Fox News yesterday
directly attacking Donald Trump now
remember Trump has spent a bunch of time
attacking DeSantis as well and you could
say that's just the silly or pathetic
Trump's going after a guy who hasn't
even said that he's actually running and
I'm with you but here is a pro de
Santa's pack going after Trump already
and DeSantis hasn't announced that he's
running for president this is
fascinating take a look Donald Trump is
being attacked by a Democrat prosecutor
in New York so why is he spending
Millions attacking the Republican
governor of Florida Trump stealing pages
from the Biden Pelosi Playbook
reading lies about social security
here's the truth from Governor Ron
DeSantis no we're not going to mess with
Social Security as Republicans what did
Trump say entitlements ever be on your
plane at some point they will be we will
take a look at them should fight
Democrats not lie about Governor
DeSantis what happened to Donald Trump
Never Back Down Inc is responsible for
the contents yeah okay so um I have to
tell you the the ad itself is pretty
lame from a factual standpoint like the
big thing that they're insisting on
talking about is cuts to Social Security
and the way that it's going is is as
follows
all of these Republicans likely at some
point played coy with whether reforming
by which they might mean cutting Social
Security and Medicare is on the table
the ad accurately points out that Trump
at one point said well I think that's
something that we're going to look at
uh Trump has alleged that DeSantis tried
to cut it DeSantis voted in favor
of a plan to reform which might have
included raising the Social Security age
of retirement age but it was non-binding
it's sort of like the factual story is
very weak they're all exaggerating about
each other's desire to cut Social
Security although I have no doubt at all
that if it was politically advantageous
they would do it what's important about
this is the fact that they attacks
themselves are a major part of what's
going on right now the uglier the
primary
the worse it is for republicans and for
whoever is the eventual nominee you will
see some people argue that a spirited
primary is a good thing for republicans
and often they will argue when you have
a tough primary it's a test of the
candidate's strength and resilience and
their ability to appeal to different
segments of the Republican electorate
and the winner is going to come out
battle tested okay that's the argument
that they make I've not seen evidence of
that what I have seen evidence of is
that the type of Republican party that
exists today is a resentful
grudge-holding Republican party with a
particularly uninformed electorate who
often only cares about one candidate
they don't really care about the
Republican party and so what we've seen
is that the more divisive the primary it
can lead to these irreparable fractures
and factions within the Republican Party
supporters of different candidates who
become disillusioned disillusioned when
their candidate loses and they may not
even end up voting in the general
election so I think in 2023-2024
this ugly Republican primary is
potentially going to turn Republican
voters off altogether through the
negativity and the mud slinging and the
fractured nature of the party if these
Republicans truly believe that an ugly
primary is good for them well it looks
like they're going to get one and we'll
be able to figure out over the next 18
months or so is this actually a good
thing for the eventual Republican
nominee I believe the answer is no if
you think this is good for the
Republican Party an ugly primary let me
know and we'll have the ad on our
YouTube channel as well as on Instagram
as well as on the Spanish YouTube
channel
davidpackman.com Spanish
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com join pacman.com
failed former president Donald Trump
spoke at the NRA convention over the
weekend and it was as insane as you can
imagine but the backdrop can't be
ignored a backdrop where we have mass
shooting after mass shooting after mass
shooting and the NRA
continues to funnel money to those
elected officials who are willing to
insist we should do nothing about guns
the problem is something else it's
anything but guns we're willing to talk
about almost blood money at this point
that these people are taking from the
NRA and Trump shows up and cheerleads
guns and instead says what about trans
and cannabis as explanations for
shootings and the backs the backdrop of
all of this
is more and more mass shootings if you
look just the last few days a mass
shooting yesterday in Biloxi Mississippi
and a whole bunch of them more than five
on Saturday in Kentucky California
Alabama mass shooting after mass
shooting after mass shooting and Donald
Trump speaks to the NRA like they're
anything short of quite frankly I think
we have to call it an evil group at this
point in time I really am careful with
the language when evil I mean wow what
other word can we use at this point to
characterize this organization and
Donald Trump shows up says nothing about
we might want to restrict some people's
access to some guns and instead says we
need a panel to look at whether trans
and cannabis cause mass shootings to
convene an independent outside panel
to investigate whether transgender
hormone treatments and ideology increase
the risk of extreme depression
aggression and even violence I think
most of us already know the answer don't
we do we really you know that's one of
those funny little it's a throwaway line
I think most of us know the answer you
don't know the answer no one in that
room has data to say trans ideology
causes mass shootings but from that we
we should investigate it but like we
kind of know the answer already we have
to look at whether common
psychiatric drugs as well as genetically
engineered cannabis and other narcotics
are causing psychotic breaks a lot of
problems we're having problems that
we've never seen before and people sort
of think they understand why we must
also be much better at detecting warning
signs of evil disturbed young men like
the one who murdered colleagues in
Louisville we cannot rest until we get
to the bottom of all of the sickness
that we're seeing in our country I will
I mean listen at least he's conceding
that most of these events are carried
out by young men I guess that's
something of an acknowledgment of
reality but he also raises this idea of
psychiatric drugs as causing mass
shootings this is usually these folks
who talk about this are more specific
and they'll actually say ssris this is
something that has been explored and of
course the the difficulty with looking
at something like that is first of all
there are so many people that are on
those medications that it can be very
difficult to find causality but also so
you have to be looking at the
possibility if you were to find some
correlation
you have to consider well it's the folks
the characteristics that got them put on
the drugs are what could be responsible
for their actions rather than the drugs
themselves that's also extraordinarily
difficult to study but they don't care
that's not you know if you sit Trump
down and try to explain that to him
you're not going to get any kind of good
faith response Trump then goes on a rant
about
refrigerators and air conditioners being
shoplifted I guess simple when you see
these gangs of hundreds of young
and apartments or Department Store in
San Francisco and Los Angeles and
Chicago
and they run in by the hundreds and
they're running out carrying
refrigerators and carrying air
conditioners and Big Stuff big little
everything fur coats non-ferco
everything that can a non-fur coats or
as we might call them coats
um caring and again remember what you to
really understand the sick and evil
nature of this you have to understand
the entire context here oh people in San
Francisco they're just shoplifting
fridges the context is
we need the guns we need the guns to
defend ourselves and others and so on
and so forth a crazy speech and even I
mean listen the audience at these things
is pretty cuckoo but even this audience
was sort of lukewarm on the nonsense
that was spilling out of Donald Trump's
mouth another strange moment during
Trump's NRA speech he displayed tweets
displayed tweets which show him ahead of
other Republican presidential candidates
in a two-way poll of
and there was another poll in Florida
where Trump was at 80.
and to Sanctus was at 15. that's a
Florida poll in Texas it's Trump 52
percent to Sanctus understand that Trump
essentially brought a PowerPoint to the
NRA convention
that's what we've got right now it's a
glorified PowerPoint to to gun nuts 20.
uh
uh you know the only way we can lose is
if we go prevent defense do you agree do
you know what that means in football
where they're holding the team to no
score and then they go prevent the last
two minutes and they lose the game we
will never go prevent but you can take
there you go and Trump notably uh very
very familiarized with sports sports
he's a big Sports guy Trump also capping
the completely unhinged deranged and
delusional and dangerous I might add NRA
speech claiming that there is a Marxist
Revolution going on and you might say
like in what country he means here in
the United States
Congress has to step up and stop this
Marxist Revolution and its tracks we
have a Marxist Revolution going on and I
think you're starting to see it I think
you're starting to see it and we have to
stop it fast this is what we must do to
save our country
[Applause]
so anyway uh Mark you know the the
entire Marxist meme from the right it's
quite laughable and to me the funniest
part about it is if you actually say to
them what is Marxism they don't have a
clue they they just don't have any idea
and you anybody who knows what Marxism
only if you had no clue what it was
might you think that there was Marxism
in the United States uh in any kind of
position of even any power influence
whatsoever but of course there are no
marxists in positions of power in the
house or senate or federal government I
mean it's it's crazy so Top Line
the most disturbing thing is that Trump
is still going and speaking to the NRA
like they're a good organization that's
the Top Line
subsequent to that is the content and
the subject matter from Trump's speech
and that's horrifying in and of itself
and they they've gone fully in
on we're not touching guns
mental health I don't know yeah mental
health but we won't fund it let's look
at mental health culture Marxism
transgender cannabis ssris but the guns
certainly not a factor whatsoever
dangerous and it's not going to change
anytime soon let me briefly mention to
you that Donald Trump exploded yesterday
and today on Truth social as a second
Trump arrest is now looming and the Fox
News Dominion trial is set to start it
was set to start today it got pushed to
tomorrow but even that there's
speculation that maybe Fox News is going
to settle
and Fox News is sort of stuck between a
rock and a hard place here because on
the one hand if Fox News settles the
Dominion lawsuit
even if they are not literally admitting
fall they are admitting fault but you're
settling it if you were if you actually
were right here if you didn't do the
things you're accused of if you were
right to air the the things you aired
and if Trump really did win 2020 then
why are you settling if they don't
settle they risk an even bigger bigger
loss weeks of humiliating headlines and
it's I don't envy the position Fox News
is in it's of course their fault that
they're in this position to begin with
Trump's idea which he posted to truth
social is Fox News should just insist
that Trump really did win in 2020. truth
Central Trump posting to Troth this
morning in all capital letters if Fox
would finally admit that there was
large-scale cheating and irregularities
in the 2020 presidential election which
would be a good thing for them and for
America the case against them which
should not have existed at all would be
greatly weakened back up back up those
Patriots at Fox instead of throwing them
under the bus and they are right there
is so much proof like Mass ballot
stuffing caught on government cameras
FBI colluding with Twitter and Facebook
State legislatures not used
Etc now Trump isn't wrong well let me
how do I even say this
a defense to defamation is that the
things you said are true
that is accurate you can defend yourself
against defamation by saying it's it
can't be defamation because I stated
truth or truth depending on your
preference of course the idea that Fox
News would try to get itself out of this
by going and making a case that Trump
actually won the 2020 election would be
so humiliating and laughable that it
could potentially be the worst possible
outcome for Fox News of all of it but
that's Donald Trump's legal advice take
it for what it's worth and then
yesterday Trump trothing also in all
capital letters quote so the Democrats
are allowed to cheat on and rig and he
spells rig with two G's which is
interesting Democrats are allowed to
cheat on and rig
a presidential election and they want to
indict Republicans for a campaign
violation this is classic so the
totality of this is Trump has been
arrested and indicted he thinks it's
politically motivated he thinks it's
bogus he thinks even if he did the thing
he's accused of it's very minor compared
to the theft of an election that he
actually won and his legal advice to Fox
on this issue is settle don't settle
fight it by arguing that I really won
which is maybe the craziest legal advice
that I've ever heard I hope
Fox does not settle the lawsuit and I
hope that we get six weeks potentially
of embarrassing humiliating and insane
headlines related to that trial which by
the way will have the sort of side
benefit of being endlessly triggering to
the failed former president
you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright so
these right wing stories about people
crying they've become so ridiculous that
they're essentially parodies of
themselves
I'm not really going to show you one of
those here from Republican senator Ted
Cruz although it certainly reminded me
of it but this actually is one of these
stories about people coming up to me the
prototypical one that Trump tells us oh
you know with the people that arrested
last week he said the people that
arrested me were crying when they
arrested me okay the the sort of subtext
of this particular story from Ted Cruz
is that whenever he lands at different
airports police just flock to him police
flock to him and they just all support
him so much and this is again it's
dubious it's always dubious when Ted
Cruz in this clip he's gonna say it's
like dozens a dozen police officers or
whatever it's probably happened at some
point
that a police officer came up to Ted
Cruz and gave him a patch or whatever
crew says here but there's a very
significant political utility to these
particular types of stories so listen to
this one and then we're going to talk
about it the most striking place to fly
into is Chicago I land at Chicago O'Hare
Airport I am with some regularity met by
10 12 15 uniformed police officers who
come
they shake my hand they give me patches
I've got my office patches of the
Chicago PD that that are displayed in my
office because those cops are so under
assault but were they crying when they
met you sir okay so it what is the point
of these stories at this point in time
the point is that it would be extremely
dangerous and damaging to Republicans
for it to become known that there is
plenty of military and law enforcement
that supports Democrats and in fact when
you look at the 2020 presidential
election one of the interesting things
about yes the military leans right
there's no question about that but one
of the interesting things about the
military vote in 2020
is that it was one of the highest levels
of support for the Democratic candidate
that Joe Biden received from members of
the military than had been seen by
democrats for a very long time I don't
remember the exact numbers they don't
really matter but the point is compared
to past elections it was a higher level
of support
and this is all
because Republicans want and to some
degree have obtained a monopoly on
certain elements of political discourse
Law and Order or As Trump once called it
law and Auto
auto insurance very very important issue
but something else altogether
Republicans use this Law and Order
messaging we are for Law and Order when
it comes to immigration when it comes to
Street crime when it comes to
demonstrations when it comes to all of
these different things and they portray
themselves as the Arbiters of Law and
Order and so they do that to appeal to
voters who prioritize safety and who
prioritize security Now understand
that it's total BS complete and total
utter BS the reality is Law and Order
means we want our political enemies
targeted but we don't want to be
targeted when we do the same things Law
and Order means we support the police
except when it's the D.C Capital police
trying to beat off rioters on January
6th of 2021 or we law order except when
it's not Law and Order no one is above
the law except when it's Trump and then
why isn't he Above the Law he should be
above the law that's the messaging and
if it became known that they aren't
actually the party of Law and Order
would be very damaging nationalism and
patriotism another element of this
supposedly so remember it's supposedly
pro-police narrative the Republican
Party often uh uh it translates or
utilizes stated support for police in
the military as a point of national
pride they must love the country more
because they support police and police
support them what that doesn't really
make any sense or the military again and
particularly when there's a crisis or a
conflict or a war
as we saw during the Iraq War under
George W Bush's presidency that can
actually be pretty useful it Taps into
feelings of loyalty and Duty among many
in the country and then thirdly this
narrative about how much police loved
Ted Cruz
it's to draw distinction with Democrats
you emphasize you know we we have the
support of police and members of the
military and that's because Democrats
are weak or they're unpatriotic or
whatever and if Democrats are seen as
being critical of law enforcement then
that contrast is even even more useful
so it's another one of these they come
up to me with tears in my eyes stories
from Cancun Ted Cruz but it is part of a
much larger political uh uh area of
political strategy that if Republicans
were to lose and they should lose it
because it's all completely fabricated
would be very damaging to them I'm going
to show you an interview of former Trump
propaganda Steve Bannon interviewing a
crazy person now I don't say that
lightly okay
one of the things in this clip that I'm
going to show you this this is Bonker
stuff I wouldn't let children see this
it's so disturbing uh Steve Bannon
interviews
a woman named Mary Beth
is that her first name is that her first
and middle name is that her first and
last name we have no idea her name is
Mary Beth supposedly
and Mary Beth says
she believes that the satanic temple is
secretly sending recruiters to school in
after school programs to recruit and
even grab children
think about that for a second and Steve
Bannon I guess kind of pretends like
Mary Beth is a sane person and one of
the what's the point here mental health
very serious issue not to be stigmatized
we want everybody to have access to
Mental Health Services it's not a joke
or any of it okay the point here is
much
of what the right has normalized as
political discourse
is the sort of stuff that really should
be handled by mental health
professionals let's listen if it isn't
in your school system it will be soon so
please be on the lookout for it
um like I said it kind of snuck up on us
we had no idea I've told people about it
they think I'm crazy when I talk about
it yeah but Google it look for it and
definitely look for it in your school
system how it goes to an after-school
program or you're one of the parents
have to work and they've got to stay
after school one of the things and he's
in the satanic people are are wandering
around the school hall because trust me
they'll be looking for they'll be
looking to grab these kids and put them
in there
so that's very concerning to me
um yeah the satanic temple has
infiltrated after school programs this
is crazy stuff and the fact that Steve
Bannon has her on and sort of pretends
like this is a real concern this is that
this is a normal thing
fuels a crisis in this country and I
want to what's it's so difficult to
address this topic
we don't I don't want to be
disrespectful nor minimize mental
illness
we also have to be clear that there are
certain things that it's not just the
difference of opinion it's not it's it's
it's something much more pernicious and
more than that and we have to be able to
say these people have lost connection
with reality we're not diagnosing any
particular person but there are paranoid
delusions that are really really common
here let me give you an analogous
situation which is actually quite sad
a lot of people from different walks of
life watch the David Pacman show and so
we get emails I'm not looking at every
email directly but I'll be notified when
certain concerning things come up and
we've had everything from people who
said they were suicidal
and we were fortunately able to get
medical services involved and to help
them and we later heard from these
people it I really appreciate that
actually that that you know
that my emails just didn't go nowhere
that somebody's monitoring this stuff
even if it's not me we all sorts of
different situations
there are about
10 or so instances where people were
writing to to me they you know they were
writing to me as far as that they knew
at least with what are called in the
mental health field ideas of reference
which
is sort of like when people watch the
show and I'm just speaking to the entire
audience and people start to believe
that I'm sending them a message
specifically and this is sometimes
called ideas of reference and the way it
usually goes is we will get emails from
folks
who will say something along the lines
of I was able to understand based on the
way David's eyes looked while he was
saying something that he was signaling
me there was one which was really sad
which was someone thought that I was
blinking messages in Morse code to them
totally unrelated to the subject matter
about which I was speaking okay
that's that's like a really really sad
thing
and oftentimes these emails will be
completely intermixed with completely
wacky political ideas and I understand
that it can be difficult to draw the
line between where we just have a
political idea and where we go over into
some kind of mental illness and and
again without diagnosing any particular
person with any particular condition we
can have a disagreement about what the
tax rate should be and we would like
mostly say that these are these are sane
conversations and we could be right or
wrong about what's the best tax rate for
this that or the other that would be
very clearly on one side of the spectrum
very clearly on the other side of the
spectrum would be like David you're
you're blinking a message in Morse code
to me okay but then you start to get
into stuff like Flat Earth
and we've talked to experts about
conspiracy theories and these sorts of
things where Flat Earth yeah it's it's
an idea that's sort of like about the
nature of our world but it it is it's so
widely demonstrated that it's wrong that
it can start to kind of eek into some
and then we go into some of the vaccine
stuff well this is all a plot by the
Deep state to
um inject some kind of dormant bio
weapon and then in 2029 Bill Gates will
flip a switch and all of the vaccine
that's been injected into people will
turn them into zombies geez that that
starts to be closer to David's blinking
messages in Morse code to me I don't
know where the line is but one of the
real problems and challenges we have
right now
is that too much stuff that is at best
gray area
and at worst outright paranoid delusions
has become acceptable political
discussion among the American right wing
at this point in time
I don't know how we fix it this isn't
about being anti-religious this isn't
about any it's about being anti-insanity
and we have to stop the normalization of
this stuff and Mary Beth saying the
satanic temples grabbing children at
after school
it's pretty gray if not on the far end
of that Spectrum to me let me know what
you think we have a voicemail number
that number is 219 to David P
here is a caller who I think believes I
really did lose my YouTube channel I
don't even know what that would mean but
this caller seems to believe I lost my
YouTube channel
and mentions not Satan but Satan Satan
I've never heard this before listen
hey where'd You Go I mean on YouTube
I've seen that ring of fire
I think I think what the caller means is
Farren filled in for me last week not
even on there you're all gonna have a
ring of fires called the Lake of Fire
and I hope you like swimming with Satan
Satan okay
um I I did not actually get kicked off
of YouTube it was an April Fool's gag on
April 1st weeks ago
everything's fine
and I don't know what to do about Satan
but I will certainly uh look into it
we've got a great bonus show for you
today oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves as bad I'm
going to tell you all about my trip last
week got recognized by some interesting
folks over in the UK had a confrontation
with a customs officer at JFK airport on
my way back so many stories some of
which maybe are remotely interesting to
you on today's bonus show producer Pat
will join me so much to discuss sign up
at joinpakman.com get instant access to
the bonus show and use you can use the
coupon code indicted or indicated
whichever spelling you prefer indicted
or indicated both get you a discount at
joinpakman.com
thank you